Hello I’m Simon Whistler, you’re watching
Today I Found Out, and in the video today,
we’re looking at how big rain drops can
be and why they don’t get arbitrarily large.
Let’s get started.
No no no no no.
Come on now.
But it’s working!
Oh come one, you don’t even have a British
accent and that beard color, what is that,
it’s all wrong.
It’s all wrong.
At only about half as wide in diameter as
a U.S. penny, the largest raindrops ever recorded,
between 8.8 mm and 1 cm, were observed by
scientists in the clouds above Brazil (1995)
and the Marshall Islands (1999).
It is unknown, however, if these bad boys
ever reached the ground at that size.
So why can't raindrops grow to arbitrarily
large sizes?
To begin with, let's talk a little about how
raindrops actually form.
Raindrops are more than just water; the vapor
in a cloud has to have something to condense
around, without which there would be no rain.
Called condensation nuclei, little particles
in the air, from dust, smoke or even salt,
sit at the center of the tiny droplets that
begin to form in a cloud.
These tiny droplets, usually between 0.001
and 0.005 mm in diameter, at first form a
nearly spherical shape thanks to the relatively
strong cohesive forces between the water molecules.
As the water drop is buffeted around in the
air, it collides with other drops, and these
small drops coalesce into larger and larger
droplets.
Ultimately the water drop will become large
enough to fall to earth.
When this happens, the surface tension of
the water that keeps the drop more or less
spherical is partially overcome by the airflow
pressure on its lower surface as it falls.
This causes the bottom of the drop to flatten
out, while the top retains its rounded shape.
Thus, contrary to the popular perception of
a teardrop shaped raindrop, thanks to the
various pressures the water drop is subjected
to as it falls to the ground, the raindrop
actually tends to look sort of like a kidney
bean or the top of a hamburger bun.
For very large droplets, it can even start
to look something like a jellyfish bell, with
this usually happening when a raindrop reaches
around 4 mm across.
When the droplets get larger than this (at
around 5 mm), the air pressure will ultimately
overcome the surface tension of the water
completely and the raindrop will split apart.
As the drop continues to fall, it can continue
to grow or shrink as it bumps into and absorbs
or is broken apart by other droplets.
Thanks to this process, the average raindrop
that actually makes it to your head is only
around 1 to 2 mm across.
That said, scientists began recording significantly
larger drops in the 1980s while studying clouds.
For instance, in 1986, cloud physicists, using
the staple of all awesome science- lasers-
recorded raindrops as large as 8 mm in a tropical
storm over Hawaii, which was shocking since,
at the time, to quote them, "there had been
a kind of consensus that raindrops would never
get bigger than about 2.5 mm."
Even factoring in that these large drops were
buffeting about in the clouds instead of falling
to earth, the scientists were surprised to
find that they could last long enough to grow
that big without being broken apart; rather,
during that early research in Hawaii, they
found that the average lifespan of a 5 mm
drop was around a remarkable 20 minutes.
For the aforementioned 8.8 mm and 1 cm record-holding
raindrops found in the clouds over Brazil,
scientists opined that they were the product
of relatively large ash particles from fires
burning in one of Brazil's rainforests- the
larger the condensation nuclei, the larger
the raindrop can potentially be, at least
to a point.
As for the similarly sized raindrops observed
in 1999 on a relatively clear day in the Marshall
Islands, they hypothesized that these droplets
formed around salt nuclei and that there must
have been an unusually high content of liquid
water in a narrow area of clouds which caused
the droplets to collide more frequently, but
without breaking, forming these mega-drops.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video, if
you did, please do give it a thumbs up below
and don’t forget to subscribe.
I’d also like to thank our patrons on patreon,
who help keep this channel going.
If you’re interested in making a small donation,
please do follow the patreon link in the description
below, we’ve got loads of great perks for
those who donate, so please do go check those
out, and thank you for watching.